how do we deal with this it's not like
we're scrap we're starving for water
right now and we have to build a fire
with sticks because that would be harder
than what we're doing right now right
that's what i keep saying and there are
a lot of people who don't accept reality
the reality is you are a privileged
wealthy individual in america all of
this stuff is a gift we're lucky to have
we shouldn't let anyone take it from us
if it's ours and we worked for it we
built it
but at the same time
if it came down to my principles
and all of the luxury i would accept my
principles that's why that's why i said
if youtube emailed me right now and they
were like tim you must show us your
proof of vaccination otherwise we will
not allow you to upload i'd be like i
guess i guess we're not doing youtube
yes we're done
that's that's a hard line i'm not i'm
not okay with that
for the time being you know we get to
live in luxury we just speak our minds
we get to challenge these systems and
we'll keep doing it until we can't yeah
stop giving youtube ideas okay this is
something that they might actually
implement because
every company over 100 people you know
mandated by our supreme
uh
geriatric overlord
has dictated to us that over 100 people
if you run a company you need to get you
know vaccinated youtube the content
creators could be considered employees
because we are uploading and working a
part of the system and who knows how far
they will push it i think they're going
to try to push it as far as they can and
the only thing that will continue to
allow this push is people's ignorance
and compliance so if you think you have
to comply if you don't know that there's
other alternatives if you don't know
that there's other possibilities if you
just blindly just say yes overlord i
will do what you tell me you don't
understand that that situation will
deteriorate and only keep getting worse
and worse and worse since the overlord
will keep asking for more and more from
you which is why i say no yeah yeah
because you can't comply your way out of
tyranny yeah this is a classic case of
feeding the alligator in the hopes that
it eats you last it's still gonna eat
you in the end maybe you should what if
i eat a truck yeah i'm in a cage with an
alligator and i trick it it's busy
eating something light stocks
alligator yeah you can get it to eat
itself he didn't see that one coming
with its own tail yeah i like it yeah i
think i think history is uh plagued with
examples of people who are like if i
just duck
death will pass my door i think that
we're especially at risk of this in our
super super cushy environment we don't
believe that it's ever really going to
get that bad and we're wrong and we're
facilitating it and we're making it
easier for it to happen well we're also
very comfortable and we're very fat
exactly uh literally fat yeah diabetes
and obesity skyrocketed up uh you look
you want to look at core mobilities
especially with covid um
that's definitely one to really look at
and have another conversation about but
there's a there's a meme that i just
posted a few hours ago and said uh and
it says we're still complying so we're
going to be fine right and it's people
you know world war ii yeah i'm not going
to say it there's no there's no there's
no there's no
there's no this is before any kind of
action happened but it specifically
highlights you know a point in history
where a lot of people did think that if
we just do what the government wants us
to do everything will be fine
and if you have this kind of naive
ability you don't know history uh and
people are fighting over toilet paper
right they fought over toilet paper last
year
shelves were emptied today's show says
there's going to be more food shortages
we're hearing that there's you know
economic collapse underway biden's
agenda is failing whether it would work
or not
people are we're hearing more reports
that when christmas comes around the
surge in demand with a lack of supply
will cause a major crack in the economy
and you will not be able to find certain
foods at your stores and then people say
to him i have no choice but to comply my
kids need food and i'm like you don't
get it dude the complying is why your
kids don't have food why they won't have
food
because they shuttered the economy
destroyed your business and still you
complied that's the crazy thing to me
how many hundreds of thousands of
businesses were destroyed how many
people were left starving they had no
pla they had no food to eat they were
angry they were demanding how many
people in new york city lost their
businesses
and now after being beaten over the head
with what the government did they come
out of the vax mandate and these small
businesses say okay if i comply this
time
everything will be okay and still the
today show nbc and this news outlet say
the food shortages are getting worse but
people are just like if i just keep
doing the same thing the fire will stop
burning me yeah farmers were literally
told
burn your crops kill your farm animals
um and they're still getting some orders
like that from the top levels of the
federal government and i think the
economic warfare here is extremely
significant because when we look at the
small businesses that were destroyed
that were shuttered by people saying
just follow the laws just follow the
rules just comply just it's just two
weeks slow the spread we need to lock
down when that happens that took away
people's economic freedom and when
people have a little bit of money they
have a little bit of freedom they have
more choices they have more options when
you take away their money when you take
away their ability to put food on the
table when you take away their ability
to make any kind of living for
themselves they're forced into
subjugation they're forced into a ubi
system they're forced into saying
government please give me a lot of your
money i think that's why another reason
the federal government gave so much
unemployment benefits that had another
very negative repercussions for our kind
of domestic economy but economies
worldwide are being shattered they're
being utterly destroyed billionaires are
becoming richer than ever and these are
because of the top-down centralized
economic policies that have been
literally locking people down in their
own prisons in their own homes telling
them you can't leave you can't go
anywhere and this is going to again
exacerbate this problem and we still
have not felt the larger ramifications
of the economic consequences because of
that the labor shortages the supply
shortages this is just the beginning and
complying is driving it that's right
there's the story of a man he walks up
at a circus and he sees an elephant tie
a full-grown elephant with a single
little rope tied around its foot and
then to a single little peg hammer in
the ground
and the elephant won't escape and he
says i don't understand why the elephant
doesn't escape and just rip out the the
peg and leave and the man says well when
they were little we tied them to the peg
and they weren't strong enough to break
free they've spent their whole life tied
to it and they don't realize they've
become strong enough to break you know
break free from this it's like why we
wear clothing
just kidding keeps you warm yeah
that's why we're clothing in the desert
i actually don't want to get bit by
mosquitoes you should go to burning man
you don't need to wear clothing there
you don't need to wear clothing you
don't need to wear clothing at pride
events we are we're trained animals man
we've trained ourselves as a species
that's very interesting when you i like
to break that stuff down and think about
all the little things that we've been
trained to do that maybe aren't really
all that good yes it's just but
elephants are are intelligent and the
the point of the story is not to say
that we're as dumb as animals it's to
point out that we have the power
we just haven't realized it i mean the
founding fathers did they're like hell
nah
yeah that's a really critical point
about actually like the compliance is
the reason your kid's hungry because
like i remember in 2020 in california i
couldn't get a haircut like i just went
from place to place called place to
place they were all closed and i finally
like called the dozenth place or the
20th place and this guy was just like
yeah i'm open i was like really you're
open oh i go in just like really you
never you never close down he's like no
you know why i'll tell you something
funny i have a lease
and as long as i pay the money that that
lease says i can be here
he just said no and he stayed open
didn't close one day yeah and i'm
thinking about the other people it just
did close because they were just like oh
well i guess i have to when people say
you know i can't risk my kids you are
literally risking your kids it's the
craziest thing to me that people have
complied from day one and it's only
gotten worse there's a meme going around
saying how many people who who told you
that after we get the vaccine things go
back to normal feel really stupid right
now
nothing's back to normal it's only
getting worse
another thing that was very interesting
about the lockdowns that is that it also
kind of brought back to life the black
economy uh because i remember even
hiring barbers to come to my house and
give me haircuts at my house and there
was a whole underground uh economic
system that that started there were
speakeasies there was underground
parties there was secret rooms where
people gathered and that's why i think
there's going to be more financial
ramifications there's going to be more
dedolorizations there's going to be more
incentives to get rid of cash and and i
think this is all coming full circle
with the 2030 agenda build back better
they're openly calling for it biden is
openly announcing his legislation is a
part of it uh boris johnson is literally
cracking open beers and spreading butter
saying build back butter and build back
beer in the most ridiculous stupid dad
jokes that are promoting a globalist
agenda that are truly about again making
sure that you're you owe nothing you
have no privacy and you allegedly will
be happier more than ever and to clarify
the agenda is klaus schwab's
basically his economic forum he wants to
invite corporations to take over as
global governance in accordance with
governments like national government he
doesn't think that they can handle them
on their own so he wants corporations to
step in and start to govern us these
authoritarian machines that we've given
personhood to that can fire you at will
to be the governor it does just is not
at all synergizing with the united
states of america and the founding of
the country and the concept of the
country
they don't they don't view this country
he doesn't understand this country no no
no no they they they've already look
this country is under an occupation okay
they're they're they're you can argue
there's two factions out of the many
different ways to describe the factions
but one is true americans and the other
is woke internationalism these are
people who say the country wasn't
founded in 1776. okay well we know from
american history it was signing of the
declaration of penance set forth this
great new nation they say nah 1619 we
made stuff up and now it's true those
people don't believe in the history of
this country they don't believe in the
ideals of this country they don't like
the founding fathers they tear down
statues of frederick douglass a man born
into slavery and then becoming one of
the greatest american heroes which we
built statues for this guy they take
down statues of abraham lincoln they do
not like this country they don't support
this country but there are people
working in the fbi and the doj in local
police departments who just don't care
the country was gutted complete
demoralization we've lost touch with our
values and what makes this country
strong and now we have police officers
in seattle willing to enforce the law
against those who would oppose antifa
it's like a doj going after parents
the first saying don't teach my kids
this garbage the federal reserve's like
one of those funguses that get in the in
the ant's brain and makes it like climb
up and get eaten and it got into the
united states in 1913 with the federal
reserve and it made us like
you know malfunction and now we're like
wasting away and starving twitching on
the ground and it's still in our brain
so we need to extract it and heal this
body
i don't think it's possible you gotta
heal it slow otherwise your shock will
kill the system that's why i said i
think what's to happen is that the
country breaks apart but look in the end
that's still beneficial for woke
internationalism
i don't think globalism is necessarily
the right word because i don't think
these people actually care about that
they're they're largely focused on the
west the europe and
in the us they don't care about china
you know for the most part and i think
that is it's that it's a it's a it's
like a um it's a cult
it is a cult of people who despise
western enlightenment who despise
critical thought and american history
and and european history and that's it
and the end result will be it all breaks
apart
in in the end we will live better lives
your kids will have food you'll have to
do more work you'll have to actually go
and probably plant some food and learn
how to farm again it won't be that
rudimentary you'll still have you know
farms who take care of you for the most
part but cities boy you're in trouble
how much of your food is imported from
california or from other countries a lot
california for sure if california breaks
off man wow i'll tell you this
all the food is grown by republicans for
the most part so those big cities are in
trouble but then they're not gonna start
just sharing all the food with everybody
nebraska man they're gonna have a
monopoly on corn i'll tell you that yep
well even during the great depression
during those times there was still a far
significant higher number of farmers and
self-sufficient people and there were
still a lot of people who were hurt by
the great depression but predominantly
hurt in major urban areas major big
cities now there's been a huge
distribution of farmers
to city slickers and there's been a big
migration to people to live in cities so
i i do feel if there is some larger
economic ramifications that the
reverberations will be far more
significant and they will hurt far more
people especially with this larger
demographic change that we have seen
throughout the last few decades thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you